I guess anybody having a son around now
you kind of look at me go it's not going
to be as good mate it's just not it's
not going to be quite as good I think
men of rightly in some cases looked at
the language they use of women and
whether or not they're making women feel
uncomfortable I don't see any such thing
happening with women
a bloke will you know it'll fix the
washing machine all that steady I fixed
the washing machine yes bloke point
right there did you feel your
testosterone right that they're both
looking at work yeah the car
manufacturers now routinely no longer
put spare wheels in the booth of a car
yeah and I just thought that's just a
massive slap in the face for for us
because they've looked awesome going nah
if you like so what's going on with you
I haven't made me tense yeah it did it
made you tense it made me tense I don't
like it I mean The Waterboy needs to be
is there needs to be a long do it while
it might don't like it
feelings
the design of the original Stormtroopers
outfit it just looks [__] great right
the same women are stormtroopers I'm
saying women are Fascist Stormtroopers
but so it is when you're ready for a
divorce
so it could also be possible
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is one of our favorite
people ever to have on the show he
returns for the 730th time uh his
comedian and his new book is called the
British bloke decoder Jeff norcott
welcome to trigonometry it's good to be
back you know I was just thinking the
last time I was with you guys I was
talking about about why labor was
screwed eternally and what we would have
10 years of conservative rules so you're
known for your great predictions Jeff
aren't you yeah well at the time it felt
right you know but uh but things have
changed I've definitely the worst thing
is as well over the years is that each
time look I've had to wear a bigger type
jumper here because every time I see
myself on it I'll just see a man I'll
just see a man aging over the years that
we we have that every day mate we all
mate I see pictures of me from five
years ago I was like my hair was black
yeah I wasn't going to bring it up but
that is you have lost weight though yeah
I have mine so you're doing better
you're doing better on some things this
this is this is quite sort of touchy
feeling we're trying to reassure each
other about how well let's talk about
men yeah blokes blokes blokes right so
first of all as you know yeah big
International audience now you're not
showing off or anything what's a bloke
Jeff uh blow well I wrote the bloke the
British bloke decoded because I sort of
thought for a while after like me too
and stuff you know there's a lot of
stuff that certain kind of men that
needed like a recording right the Harvey
weinsteins and you know people like
toxic men are doing genuinely dodgy
stuff but what happened I think a lot of
people agree now that other things fell
into that slipstream and there was a
period for quite a while where the male
brand just well it slumped a bit if it
was a stock market live moment yeah but
it feels like you know like 1950s
looking good looking good and then it
just you know share price and then and
then I sort of felt that you know there
are there are certain men who absolutely
needed to be taken to task but I also
thought that there's the bloke of which
I'd probably see myself being part of
that group and I think it is quite a
British thing you know in fact other
cultures don't really have like an exact
equivalent of this word it's just I
don't know you steady guy likes the
stuff he's supposed to like like me you
know I'm very basic in the sense that my
favorite food is curry you know my
favorite drink is lager you know
favorite sitcom is Fools and Horses you
know my favorite documentary is the
making of Fools and Horses I'm just uh
there's one from the tour and and so I
kind of thought that's who I am and I
felt like during that time we had to
basically shut up and listen but the the
words we felt like we were drawn into a
very negative pejorative of what being a
bloke was and I thought maybe it's time
for a sort of I don't know like the book
is supposed to be like a sympathetic
stock take of where the British bloke is
and do you think the fact that you're
you're a dad and you have a son yeah I
remember actually the very first time we
interviewed you and you know of all the
comedians we've had on the show you're
probably the most affable out of the
people who actually are willing to
challenge the mainstream culture a
little bit you've got massive this to
every single other comic has been on the
show no no no no no I [__] them I'll
take it yeah what I mean is actually I
think you you have a way of framing your
opinions and your comedy in the way that
makes it easy for people on the other
side so to speak to here yeah but when
we ended our last question you actually
brought up something about men and boys
that I thought was like that's quite
Jeff clearly feels strongly about that
so did becoming a father of a boy kind
of make you think about it in a slightly
different way yes I think because you
sort of for most of my life I would say
that and this might be controversial the
other way that being a bloke and male
has been a bit of a touch you know I
mean it's uh it's more of a laugh
generally it is more of a laugh yeah I
would say it's more of a lot less
meaningful connections but more of a
laugh but I thought I guess anybody
having a son around now you kind of look
at them you go uh it's not going to be
as good mate it's just not it's not
going to be quite as good and and you
sort of think so what in a way and it's
interesting you mention that because
that is sort of where the book starts is
is baby and bath water what aspects of
what I deem to be blokary do I think are
worth passing down and the book starts
with a sort of anecdote about my son uh
being involved in a bit of banter in the
playground and and and him not
understanding why the other boys seem to
be being mean to him but me taking great
pleasure and going no so what that is is
Banter they're just testing you out to
see if you're weak and whether it's not
you'll be able to withstand the hunt you
know and I started getting some very
detailed kind of primitive stuff and and
by the time I'd finished explaining
banter to him he was like I don't really
like band titles don't like banter and
so he's American man yeah he's bad yeah
what would it be trash talking trashing
each other oh yeah really we love
America so much and we go there yeah
more and more but banters just they
don't have it Trash Talk busting each
other's balls yeah yeah so yeah I I mean
that he takes things very literally so
that wouldn't have helped us but the um
but so what other things are there that
are quite complicated Concepts you know
certain things that get a lot of stick
in modern discourse right so things like
man up I believe in this phrase man I
don't see a problem with it and and they
they came a period I remember there was
and I talked about it in the book but
there was an advert for Lloyd's Bank
you know these adverts right they go
they go which way is the culture wind
blowing oh yeah yeah blokes are [__] man
up so this advert was a string of
celebrities basically saying that they
hated the phrase man up and I thought
that's a real shame because I think
obviously anything can go to excess
right if you're man enough means that I
don't know you don't go a chemo that's
bad that's too far but I think for the
most part like a phrase like man up man
up is sort of like a call to arms for
men isn't it it's basically saying take
yourself less seriously take some
responsibility for the situation fall
back a bit you know like if if you've
got like a load of family staying over
and there's not enough beds right and
you're just deciding who's going to
sleep on the couch it's really
uncomfortable makeshift bed is it going
to be Granddad no is it going to be the
women middle age no he's gonna be the
kids no it's gonna be the younger male
you know and I think that's quite a good
thing to make yourself less important
and I also thought it's a shame because
the amount of things that blow could lay
claim to seem to be diminishing whereas
the amount of things that women sort of
celebrate about themselves is fairly
well established you know in terms of I
mean that song by I'm Every Woman you
know yeah I mean literally claiming to
be like [__] oracles and it's all I
can read your thoughts right now and
nobody really challenges that so I
thought could we just keep could we keep
Manning up so the book is in a
light-hearted way I guess trying to to
offer up Arguments for why things like
banter and man flu exist and what kind
of function they they have oh and it's
any point because
if you look at what's going on in our
society where
You could argue particularly certain
elements of it demonize men and then
everyone Rings their hands when you get
a figure like Andrew Tate emerge and go
why is this this is terrible what why is
it you've been trashing men forever
however long you've been saying they're
toxically masculine they're evil blah
blah blah obviously someone who comes
along and is going to subvert that is
going to get a huge audience yeah I mean
I suppose the argument that progressors
might make is they'll often say well
you've had 2 000 years Lads and I I just
think all right I can understand that as
a man of 46 that I've had certain
privileges at times I can see that I
just don't know if you're a 12 year old
boy whether that makes as much sense
less so if you're a seven-year-old boy
and every single animation you seem to
watch seems to involve a strong female
lead and a nervous guy who gets there in
the end right I started to notice that
all these films all these kid films so
it's nice for me to be represented I'm
going to be honest with you I mean I
watched a Super Mario film and I thought
Mario is the absolute hero of that but
of course he can't get over the line
without Princess Peach can money just
explaining everything that he's doing
wrong and her being heroic and him just
reluctantly almost falling over the line
as as a hero figure so I guess yes
people like Andrew Tate come into that
space and it's I think most young males
would would see the issues with some of
what he's saying but mainly they're just
like well there's somebody Ada is
celebrating you know masculinity which
is
um you know something they might not see
as much certainly in Western popular
culture but also just on a simple level
you know not just him but like the the
sort of manosphere as it's called he's
they're saying things that just seem
true I guess when they start saying
women like guys with money they're like
yeah you know that that's that's
reasonable you know uh women like tall
guys we're like athletic guys and yet
you know there's the kind of thing that
if you were on a discussion panel show
on Radio 4 you'd have to caveat is it
right yeah you'd have to go look it
could be said it could be said that in
certain scenarios and I'm by no means
all and you have to do all these weird
[__] small print terms and condition
things and you go yeah but in wider
Britain not of these things aren't
contentious you know so there's some
stuff which is a defense of things you
know which I think is is something that
maybe is timely but also just trying to
scratch beneath the surface of some of
our idiocy like why don't we wear sun do
you wear Sun cream when you're no hot
country no no no no no I knew he
wouldn't I'm off South American mate I
should be able to come out there and
come back looking like a bronze Adonis
well that's not what happens though you
come out looking like a crab I mean
you're South American you're whiter than
both of us yeah
you're the whitest guy in the room I am
and I take great pride in that
these but you don't like Pride man yeah
and what about you do you wear Sun cream
when you're on a holiday uh not for the
first couple of days and then and then I
eventually classic yeah mate because you
know
but but but then my wife eventually
turns out to be have been right yeah of
course and we should we should probably
have some protection against the hottest
thing in our universe but but they so I
looked at the question of why don't men
wear Sun cream right right and I thought
you could just pass it off as bravado or
ignorance you know or just silliness a
lot of times blokes are put into that
kind of pigeonhole they also thought
about the act of
moisturizing your body on a beach now
women will generally use more creams you
know Night Cream Day Cream they'll take
more care of their body a bloke won't
often do any of that stuff and then
suddenly he's in a public space and he's
supposed to basically engage in what he
might feel looks like an act of
self-love right and and the worst thing
is you've got to get to that bit there
that is such a weird you know get into
your lower back it's almost like you
know when a cat has to lick their chin
and they they lose all their [__]
dignity like straight away so I thought
there's more going on here than just
blokes being uh sort of uh trying to be
Alphas or or being emotionally retentive
it's actually about match Fitness in
terms of self-preservation of our own
bodies we just don't do it that much so
on the two times of years we're on a
beach and we're expected to do it we
have a bit of a reticence we feel
awkward so it doesn't necessarily say
that that's a wise Behavior but it's not
just blockheadedness it's not and you
know what's really interesting about
seeing the younger generation like for
me and you we came so we came of age at
that kind of post-raved generation the
sort of post Brit pop
the uh you know naughty's late 90s where
it was all about going out you know
doing drugs getting getting messed up
and you look at this new generation now
and the pressure for them to look good
and to be ripped and to be buff men
we've never had that it was all about
how much you could take on a night out
yes and I think so the first time I
appeared on the show and I was I did say
about the objectification of men would
would eventually become an issue it
hasn't fully come into view yet but it
is funny I think whereby I think men of
rightly in some cases looked at the
language they use of women and whether
or not they're making women feel
uncomfortable I don't see any such thing
happening with women
have you been out for like dinner with a
group of middle-aged women or a bit a
bit of Prosecco and then if the weight
is a bit good-looking oh mate what the
way that they speak to him you're like
you're being creepy but often it won't
occur to them that it's possible for
them to be creepy because in their minds
they've presumed that all men want
female attention all the time and
there's a lot of Truth in that but you
know if he's 19 years old and he's a 10
you know there's a certain kind of
attention I guess that he feels that
that he would want and and I think that
that is that has been instead of like
saying why don't we you know women have
this pressure to look good and and men
don't instead of saying why don't we
take it away from both parties all he's
done is equalized it really yeah and the
way that men are objectified like look I
mean for example I heard a uh a very
high profile film review show and they
were talking about Henry Cavill and they
there's two female presenters and they
said well he's very easy on the eye and
um and I just thought you know I I don't
care about that personally if I just
thought God if Mark hermode and Simon
mayor were going yeah she's uh she's a
bit of eye candy there
I know there's a different history and
stuff so I do think that the sexual
politics is is changing uh rapidly I
just think what you're actually
highlighting there Jeff is that this
idea that we've somehow got into where
the relationship between men and women
is portrayed as some sort of Battle of
the sexist is the most insane thing I've
ever heard because throughout human
history and almost certainly for the
rest of human history these two groups
of people are going to have to work
together to survive to thrive to raise
children
Etc and so sort of playing this like
who's up Who's down thing just doesn't
make any sense what ideally we should be
looking at is how do how do we work
together how do we understand the
differences but we seem to have got to a
point where it's like let's pretend
there are no differences other than men
are evil yeah it seems that we're we're
in the past you know women had certain
sexist presumptions about them like you
say there's an over correction and the
society does generally over correct so
no one really wins in that in that case
all you do is it is slightly try and
equalize the misery but there was a
point I was just about some [__]
great but classic blow you see forgot
the important things uh that we're
supposed to oh [__] is there anything
it's a really good
what was it you were saying oh that was
it that was it yeah
yeah I mean like the reason that that
historically Gillette advert was such a
huge [__] was was simple is that most
women have blokes in their life they
have a husband who they hopefully like
they have sons who they want to be happy
they have a father that was probably on
balance quite nice to them and stuff so
then once you start demonizing you
actually lose the broad audience because
women don't necessarily want to think
all of the the men that they know are
potential you know uh sex offenders or
indications of weird kind of male
version of a [__] Stepford Wife
has been going on far too long
we can't laugh at all
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same old excuses boys
will be boys boys will be boys but
something finally changed allegations
regarding sexual assault
so that is what
what I suppose in terms of a mass
audience You'll Always Find pushback and
you know in the book I've sort of said
that even if people you know if you're
not a bloke yourself or or if you're
married if a woman is married to more of
a you know a less sort of blokey guy
more perhaps an effeminate type guy or
if you're you know you're gay or you
will know blokes right blokes will be in
your life whether it's Brothers uncles
husbands or anything you know so it's
trying to make sense of that tribe
really you know it's a big part of
society blokes it's a big subset of them
it's not like a lad a lad is different
lad is usually young and does all this
[__] you know a geezer will often you
know walk like that a bloke I suppose is
a bit more calmer you know he wants to
be uh Dependable presence for the people
that he loves he'll do lots of lifts for
people he'll pick people up from
airports and stuff like that so it's all
very blokey stuff a bloke will you know
it'll fix the washing machine all that
steady on I mean
[Music]
I looked up on YouTube obviously but
yeah but but I looked up the parts
ordered it in took the thing apart in
front of my son
put the new part in yeah mate yeah did
you feel your testosterone respect that
they're both looking at it yeah no you
just talks no no no no no no I think I
think to build and fix is is a big part
of what we feel compelled to do now look
are our generation ever going to be up
with our granddads who would uh you know
like changing a spare tire by the side
of the road winner
we're not doing that let's be honest
that's very unlikely to happen but well
you know what's interesting I constitute
was I found out you know in the process
of writing this book that the uh the the
car manufacturers now routinely no
longer put spare wheels in the boot of a
car yeah and I just thought that's just
a massive slap in the face for for us
because they've looked at us and gone
nah
you look you're not about their life you
go see you go sit you go sit away for
the nice AAA man read your read your
family a poem you know because because
this is and I thought that's that's
actually a shame because the the trust
that your son will have had in you yeah
from seeing that moment and again and
this is what you find in the modern ages
is the short uh the terms and conditions
and the caveats it's not to say women
can't fix washing machines not to say
that women can't never it's just that I
think that you know when it comes how
many women have statistically speaking
do you think I've ever fixed a washing
machine
um well based on pornography I'm not
sure the washing machine ever gets fixed
by anybody but it's good to see you've
done your research exactly well Pawns in
other areas but yeah look let's come
back to the Gillette team because I
think that's really interesting because
to me
in the 90s the Gillette adverts were
actually basically telling men exactly
how to be healthy men yeah if you
remember those 90s Gillette adverts it
was all guys or fathers you know hugging
their son under his wedding day uh a guy
going out to work his wife just helps
him with the type oh he looks after his
baby yeah it was all about what you're
actually supposed to be you'd look at
that and you go oh you know one day when
I grow up I'm gonna have a wife and I'm
gonna have a son and I'm gonna have a
job and I'm gonna do all these things
and I'm gonna compete and I'm gonna do
well bring home the bacon and eventually
my son will get married and I'll be
there and that's kind of what you're
supposed to do as a bloke as a guy as a
man
and now we're in a position where it's
like instead of telling men how to be
healthy it's like no no this is what's
wrong with you yeah it's incredible
transformation really and I don't think
it's beneficial to men or women well
yeah that's the problem isn't it is
there's always a it's like in a
relationship between a man and a woman
there is of course advice criticism
rebuke instruction but it's got to be
part of a pie chart isn't it where a
certain amount of it is that there's
praise celebration it did seem like the
pie chart kind of circled around and a
lot of the advice you know when it's
when it comes down to you know how men
should be with their friends you know
you've got to talk more you've got to
share more and I think I do think that
that men do need to do that more but I
also think that men and women both have
an issue around that I think men need to
share a bit more their friends maybe
women need to share a bit less can we
have that conversation you don't have to
tell your friend every single like
intimate detail of what's going on in
your relationship with a man because it
it's a real dividing line that I think I
I in my whole life I don't think I've
and there is a stereotype of menus to
criticize their wives I would not sit
with you boys at a night out and just
start trashing my wife I would I would
think that you would think less of me as
a man if I did that you would think that
he's treacherous he's disloyal you know
whereas whereas it literally is the
other way around broadly speaking for
women it's a bonding exercise if two of
them are trashing their husband the
third one might just make something up
just to be part of the game just so he
kicked me in The Shins here but did he
no I just I just wanted to have
something to add to to the chat I didn't
want to seem you know I didn't want to
see him outside of of the group and I
think that that is there's always this
idea that men need to um like
emotionally correct to where women are
whereas I think there's actually
somewhere in the middle and it needs to
go on both sides there is a point with
bloke to it I love going away as a group
of blokes and talking absolute bollocks
you know it's so um it's so re reduce
that's what rejuvenates me is to just
not think of anything serious for a
while but there are points in my life
where you know a mate of mine will be
talking about his third kid and I'll be
thinking third
I didn't I don't remember the second you
know yeah and that's that's that's not
cool I think we could do and that's not
like for any great empathic reason it's
just it's not unreasonable to just be
broadly speaking up to date with the
main features of your pals lives because
the [__] hits the fan for them you want
to at least know the the name of the
woman that left him
hey KK do
you cleaning yeah but only when my wife
does it in Russian men who clean up
executed for not being real men which is
correct well for those men who
21st
[__] has an incredible for you manscaped
are the global leaders immense below the
waist grooming and have forever changed
the grooming game with their amazing
performance package 4.0 inside this care
bundle you'll find a lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker ear and nose hair
trimmer crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
brief and a travel bag to hold your
goodies this Elite trimmer is designed
to trim hair on loose skin although your
werewolves might look like a couple of
Boris Johnson's treat them with respect
and benefit from their proprietary skin
safe technology complete your grooming
game this spring with the new refined
cologne signature scent by manscaped
this stuff is legit and will have you
smelling like royalty the good kind not
prince Andrew get 20 off and free
shipping with the code trigger 20 at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code trigger 20 at man
escape.com it's time to throw out all
your old hygiene habits and upgrade your
life
it's true and I think what people don't
acknowledge as well is that there is a
fundamental difference what he said
between men and women and we need
different things from our friendships
but I want to be able to talk to my
mates about you know things that are not
going well in my life but when I see my
mates like you said I see it as a break
from reality yeah I want to go I want to
have a laugh I want to you know just
talk about you know life whatever it is
I don't particularly want to talk about
me if I'm honest you know they'll be
banter they'll be fine why is that
Francis
because see if you did that on a night
out if you're like so what's going on
with you I haven't made me tense yeah it
did it made you tense it made me tense I
don't like it I mean what everyone needs
to be is there needs to be a long do it
while it made me don't like it yeah
failing yeah well uh yeah I think that
there's definitely but there's obviously
Merit in both approaches yeah and that's
but maybe the argument I'm making is
that we've got to a point we're acting
like there's no merit in one approach
and total mirror in the other approach
because you know I I think you can
analyze problems into the ground I also
think that there are potential benefits
of you know blokes have nicknames for
each other oh yeah when you're mean to
another bloke it part when he's a mate
it's because you TR there's trust right
you can withstand it and I think that
you know I don't know many women that
have nicknames for each other probably
more working-class women have nicknames
for each other yeah but or or if they're
on a a WhatsApp group for a Hindu like
if there was people who are a bit late
paying would go come on you [__] more
you know use the kind of language that
bloats would say yeah to sort of chivvy
people up and put a rocket under someone
I think that there is a tendency to be
more agreeable you know as being
discussed quite a bit I just think that
neither are correct they're just
different approaches I don't understand
where one became bad unhealthy toxic and
the other one just escapes scrutiny and
it's also as well that we that women
don't
wind of new
but they don't really well the thing is
I think a lot of women don't even say
that they do but what's happened is a
small group of people who are more
influential in terms of media and sort
of society they're imposing their values
on everybody else and by the way you
know if you remember our Rob Henderson
in terms of like luxury beliefs quite a
lot of them will still have a manly
bloke at home but they'll [__] bang
on in the guardian about how all the men
need to you know cut their dicks off or
whatever yeah you know it's it's kind of
there was an article that all men needed
to cut their dicks
that feels like the Apex you know what I
mean you know what I mean like the it's
a kind of mismatch between I think what
most women actually want and what Elite
culture is telling them they're supposed
to want is is you know what's
interesting just then I suddenly thought
like are we are we we sell a moaning
blokes here you know like just sitting
there this is the actual only time the
blokes do talks with them podcasts or or
shows like this with exactly with each
other but that does bring me to another
aspect of of being a bloke is that
you're not expected to moan you know
you're not and that's where something I
guess like the concept of man flu comes
from which is you know there's obvious
scientific research as to why when
viruses strike men it can feel more
virulent to them but even as I'm saying
that guaranteed there's some women
watching this game you know especially
especially if they've given birth fair
enough right if you've given birth
you're out you're out of this equation
but it's kind of strange because you're
supposed to you're encouraged to talk
more about your feelings right and then
like you feel really ill shut the [__]
up about that you know so so it's
obviously selective and I get that
because you know if you're in a family
situation it's and this in a way is
where the small all see conservative
mindset comes from is born of pragmatism
if you're in a family situation where
there is a woman who's likely to be
doing more care giving for the children
you know running of the house that stuff
an ill man is really inconvenient in the
first place right secondly him moaning
about it really you just don't have time
for it so I can see why that this is
evolved but also the idea of acting like
man flu isn't a thing it sells very
close to the idea of gaslighting isn't
it you feel something's happening you
report that it's happening somebody
tells you it's all in your mind
you know well sorry just to finish that
thing I I think
um I I know what you mean about sounding
like we're moaning I I really do and I
think manfully is actually a very good
example of where understanding of the
differences between the Sexes is very
helpful like my wife understands that if
I'm Ill I I feel I don't feel well right
and we work around the likewise with her
there's certain things that she finds
more difficult than I do and I know that
about her and I'm there to support her
with that in the same way do you know
what I mean so what just going out for a
couple of days till she feels better
exactly just go out have a few drinks
with my mates she's yeah yeah wait to
wait for the weather to pass yeah I
think I mean it's yeah there are they
are just simple like you say I guess
there are there is biology there I mean
women can see a broader range of colors
so this will manifest in conversation
like I don't believe that I've ever met
a woman that would describe a color as
black you say oh that's black midnight
blue navy blue anything other than black
you know they just see a wider spectrum
of color so they sometimes might think
of bloke's being ignorant when he says
something's green when it's turquoise
it's just we're not seeing things on on
the same level and there's there's even
differences in the way that men kind of
see you know or certainly I realize now
in the comment section this might be
contestable but there's certainly
educated people that believe that men
are better with literally live tunnel
vision whereas women are better with
peripheral
uh that would make a lot of sense all of
this is basically explained why I can
never see anything in the cupboard right
this is a complex way of me trying to
this whole book is me trying to justify
to my wife as to I just can't see [__]
why don't you just go and look for
something I I don't get it but you know
if I can look to the Horizon a lot
easier and maybe there's some sort of
genetic Legacy for that and what we
don't talk about with men as well and
look it's important for women but I
think sometimes it's just more important
for men is exercise you know like you
see so many men now who talk about you
know depression and and all of these
things and of course they need to man up
according to Jeff yeah you need to
[__] deal with it mate yes
sweat depression now yeah just go and
put if you go to the gym and you have a
good session I mean you feel so much
better and More in control of your life
I think that there are a lot of women
who are mothers that have probably said
would be nice to have the time to go to
the gym and stuff like that I think
broadly what you're saying is true if
you look generally at how much space is
in people's lives they make for exercise
men would make more I think if you look
around any gym competitive Sports now
you could argue that that is a construct
but then also you know it's not a
[__] construct no no no but that's
what I mean is like if things are a
reality for long enough it's like male
and female Beauty right people just say
well female beauty is is venerated
because that's the kind of stock that we
put on it you go it's also been around a
while that idea right from the earliest
painting and stuff right from the way
that women look at each other there is
something about women that I think you
know and and this is from my prism of
heteronormativity sis although the CIS
come into it possibly but he's not I
just think there's something nicer you
can have such thing oh God I realize I'm
going to get rid of this but it's a
design classic right some things are
where am I going with this the design of
the original Stormtroopers outfit it
just looks [__] great right the same
women are stormtroopers I'm saying women
are Fascist Stormtroopers but so it is
also it sounds like you're ready for
so it could also be possible
this is [__] great it should also be
possible that maybe just one of the
bodies broadly speaking looks a lot
nicer on average than the other guys
Jeff is on his last ever tour
forever you know or he'll be on tour
forever but I mean you know in in terms
of the marriage thing it is it's just
this riddle isn't it you go you've got
these two human beings same species you
go you're different and sometimes it
will result in a row but because of that
difference sometimes you don't
understand it but then sometimes the
difference is the source of Attraction
isn't it if you look at like what a lot
of women they like big arms you know
because that's the thing that they
generally speak and don't have men will
like curves because we don't well the
ones we do no one likes the look of
overtime and I you know I also think
that curves are if you look at atoms
planets Suns orbits we sort of know that
curves really are what makes life goes
around right okay yeah there's an
interesting Theory Jeff eggs
all the good stuff is curved but but the
point that I'm making is is the the
difference is the basis of Attraction
100 for a hell of a you know four
heterosexuals most more generally right
so so if you try and chip away at that
difference what happens to attraction
well completely and the thing my wife
and I we've been married over 20 years
now that we found the most useful is
reading stuff and and understanding what
the differences are and how to navigate
them so John Gray who we've had on our
show uh he wrote that very famous book
men from Mars Women Are from Venus and
he's updated it since and whatever
that's really all it is is understanding
the psychological and physical
differences between men and women and
we're talking about depression earlier
there's quite a lot of evidence now that
one of the reasons that men's uh men are
not really getting treated for
depression nearly as as well is that the
help men need yeah is completely
different to the help women need when
they are depressed yes so they need a
different solution but quite often it's
it's a solution that's geared towards
women that is then sort of mapped onto
men and it just doesn't work very well
because men need a different thing men
need to feel competent and Powerful as a
result of whatever therapy they do
whereas for women it's more about being
heard and unpacking certain issues and
whatever do you know what I mean I do I
mean I remember oh yeah I'm a big
believer in in counseling and talking
therapies you know it took things for me
to get quite bad with me where it was
just a loss sort of throws the dice but
I remember the first counseling session
I went for
um the woman who's a therapist sort of
said you know it's okay to feel weak I
was like weak we mentioned the weak word
for why'd you mention that I don't want
to feel it no when I was gone you know
within yeah not too long at all uh do I
wanted a more you know like the head
tilt in empathy doesn't really work for
me so if I'm talking about sad things
that happen and someone says that must
have been very tough for you and maybe
this is what's wrong with me I don't
know maybe maybe I need to acknowledge
it was tough but that I I would I just
need to almost verbalize what happened
because maybe I don't reflect on it as
much so a lot of the early counseling I
did was just sort of narrativizing
things telling the story of what
happened and they go oh yeah that what
that was that was what I hated about
that or that was what made me angry and
eventually I found the right therapies
and it's it's interesting you know like
there are a lot of blokes that are still
resistant to talking therapies I think
they're a great thing to get you off the
floor I also think having done them for
a lot of years there is a point where
and this is maybe a more blokey take
that your past is just your past and you
just gotta suck it up a little bit well
you've got to go through the process
first and that's why I'm a big fan of
that stuff as well yeah the you've got
to process whatever happened but then
you've got to just accept you know your
life was your life you're moving on and
what is it that you're going to do in
the future that I think I think that's
the path really you might have to go
over like dates and stuff that make you
reflect but but yeah you go all right
that was who my parents were these were
their good things they sort of bad
things the idea that you constantly
retailed that story the the the concept
I think for a bloke of self-pity is an
important one the idea the tiny violin
is always there in our minds am I you
know like because we've had blokes
around us that will call it out often
enough and in the book the very last
chapter is I'm talking about you know is
it okay for men to cry in public and my
view is very much that it's better if we
do in private which sounds really toxic
but I you know I have a good cry
regularly but I just think that that's
where I can do it properly the problem
is the process of there being witnesses
to my tears changes the function of it
right and I and and also I just think
men don't cry as often statistically so
when we do do it we're not match fair so
we look perfect
like it just looks awful it's like this
[__] hulk-like metamorphosis whereas
you know I think you know the women I've
known in my life like my mum could cry
and like still fold clothes you know so
there's there's definitely a different
ability there and I think that male
tears hold a different status in society
so Novak Djokovic cried after the his
Wimbledon final defeat right it's nice
to see my son still there still smiling
you know
um
I love you
thank you for supporting me and uh I'll
give you a big hug and we can all
love each other thank you nobody
Djokovic ladies and gentlemen something
within him broke and we're like
that's wonderful you know this strong
guy this athlete that's got all the way
he's earned this but if he cried like
that after the quarterfinal we'd be like
okay mate you know yeah it's a bit much
yeah just get back to the locker room
somebody put a towel over his head and
and you could say that that is toxic or
anything but it's always that's really
you know I don't think you can
completely ignore the base reasons why
that emotional impulse exists in the
first place so again it's like yourself
counting it's working with what is there
in blokes really and what is there in
place is different and the language of
therapy can sometimes seem a bit alien
yeah it's so important to find a good
therapist because part of what I think
in the process of moving on is to
acknowledge what's happened accept it so
and then accept what's happened and then
put things in place in order to help you
move on constantly revisiting the same
trauma all you're doing after a while is
just picking it a scam and you're not
letting yourself heal yeah and I think
the people people find that over the
time I mean I suppose that there are
that's where our friendship groups could
come into it a bit more maybe if it was
like you know a pit stop as such not a
full-like kind of like in new engine but
just the tire change with each other
like when we go out for a beer I mean
one of the things I spoke about in in
the book as well is about beer and the
process of going for a pint and why that
appeals to bloke so again it's this
really surface level thing you know it's
a good question why do why do men like
beer they do you know he's an
interesting one right for the liberal
Elite right and you can play along at
home if this is like a Tea Time quiz
what do you think is a top selling lager
in the UK it's going to be something
[__] like Fosters
Constantine
he's trying to suppress Carling calling
he's got it calling after all these
years you know and it's really
interesting there's almost a metaphor
for blokiness right that I think that's
been the way since more or less the 90s
so that just shows you how stable the
state I like what I like I don't like
change yeah I I like what I like I don't
really even like it
if I'd imagine that maybe you're more
Metropolitan Elite type viewers might
have gone little or toffee flavored IPA
and stuff but if you if you look outside
of London Manchester Newcastle you get
out there think of all these pubs all
these Backwater pubs have just been
serving Carling
um all these years and and you know just
drinking a lager and sitting in a pub it
it's one of the few times men can sit
opposite each other without an uh a game
or a distraction you know because you've
got a pine you've got you can get away
you know I'll never go for a meal with
just enough just way too [__] tense
right just sitting there but whereas you
know a pub will have distracted for a
meal together yeah and I felt tense
yeah
exactly where it was it was in
Shrewsbury
and I delivered really picked you know
like the one where you're against the
wall yeah because I knew it'd make me
feel tense so I had better sight lines
yeah it's an airport goes on in our head
but a pub is good because it has
distractions you know so so you can
really you know there might be sport or
they might be a snooker table for
whatever reason those you know blokes 10
to 10. one Theory I heard about that is
that men you know used to spend most of
the time that they would spend together
hunting and so they they're naturally
sort of feel more comfortable facing in
the same direction next to each other
right whereas women will tend to be sort
of in a huddle type of thing because
that's what they'd be doing do you know
what I mean that's just too much
scrutiny man yeah yeah just be they
might they might see the truth yeah if
they're looking at me like that yeah and
it's you know you you see it as well
with you know with and I know football
fans can sometimes be obnoxious but I do
think it plays a vital role in society
yes for men to be able to go together to
watch a game you know to bond to say
horrible stuff that they would never say
within the confines of their own home
and it's a pressure valve isn't it it's
a purge I mean I mean it is a purge of a
form of like Primal scream therapy but
what's interesting and I mentioned this
you know in the book is about football
clubs like people often miss out the
element of a club right that was how
they originally formed like Aston Villa
and Birmingham city were formed in that
area around that time because there was
a lot of kind of uh you know sort of
feckless young men that were getting
involved in the ferris activities you
know trying to keep them out of gangs
like the peaky blinders essentially
let's have a place for these these young
fellas to go so there's a community
element and and I think blokes do invest
a lot into that so when you see the
stadium you know when the clubs get a
new stadium and you see these grow
absolute Silverbacks outside they're
crying it does look a bit odd to some
people but like there's way there's so
much invested in there you know it might
be where their father took them and I
you know I do speak a lot about sport um
in the book of course you know female
participation this ball is is going up
dramatically but overwhelmingly you know
it's something that men seem to feel
that they need
in in their lives maybe it's like a
coded conversation isn't it you know and
and one one of the aspects of being a
bloke a really key aspect of being a
bloke is that you think the game's
changed yeah it's not what it was no
it's not as physical I'll tell you what
next year it will be worse you know to
some point I guess when you're about 13
where you thought sport was perfect yeah
because you just found it and ever since
then it's been getting progressively
worse every bloke thinks that there's
almost no yeah you know maybe one or two
exceptions but you know I suppose once
you get
um Saudi regimes running football clubs
maybe really has got worse but it's also
as well what's really interesting and
we're talking about sport getting worse
which is something that I think is no
suntan cream Sports getting worse yeah
you know I just tick every box but it's
it's the lack of physicality in sport
you do there's a part of me it goes yeah
feminization is society look at them one
little tap they're rolling over I
remember two not even a yellow card mate
well I mean but interestingly you look
at some of the things of sport are
contacting hugging strangers singing
fair you know singing having a sing song
it's not the most overtly masculine
thing that you could think of and if you
think of uh football clubs that their
their most notable songs are quite
emotional like Liverpool You'll Never
Walk Alone uh Man City seeing true uh
Blue Moon yeah
I'm forever blowing bubbles I love that
song it's so incongruous but yet there
must be a reason for that because in in
sport like you say there's all these men
that go in there they're this balloon
that's just waiting a burst yeah it is
you know I love that song because for
our American viewers and people you know
who watch sports particularly Americans
it's about celebrating success yeah West
Ham song is called on forever buying
Bubbles and one of the lyrics in it is
the bubbles they fly so high but like my
dreams they fade and die Fortune's
always right I mean it's so enigmatic
yeah it is really odd and also it should
be said for the American audience the
West Ham would be perceived to be to
have quite a blokey sort of manly uh uh
fan base as well so you know a lot of
the book is about that you know why do
we like Curry why do we like pints why
do we like sport but try not to just do
it in a too basic a way to genuinely
scratch beneath so why do we like
courage well Curry because it involves
Jeopardy I think partly again it's a
routine as well as a dice yeah it's a
bit of it can be a roll of the dice I
mean I think that one you don't have to
organize it I don't know if anybody's
ever pre-booked to Curry and if it is
it's probably one of your more middle
class mates to start so oh yeah you know
the the chef trained and goer you're
like all right Tim but generally you
just rock up and and like you know the
great the blokes that work at Curry
houses are just the most like sort of
practical-minded people do they have you
booked have you ever been asked that no
at Curry House and they don't often
don't even say like do you want a beer
they go how many Cobras yeah how many
papadums right so I know exactly what
you're going for you're going for the
same [__] thing you had the last 20
years and then and then there's this
this element of of self-expression one
in how you deal with the pop-a-doms in
the first place you know how you whether
you you smash them or whether you try
and get a lot of different things on
like a pizza are where it's just one
thing and then what Curry you choose you
know and a lot of young people you know
that bravado element of going for a well
first it was like vindaloo but then do
you remember there was a fall yes there
was this murmurines of this spicy
alternative called a file and I had a
file and I don't think I've ever been
the same since I just think I'd I've
messed up something in my interesting
broken by a fan oh yeah broken by a file
but you know I used to do like like I'd
used to eat lime pickles straight from
the thing just as like um a show of
bravado uh to the to the troop I mean I
did I did often think that they should
just like do some sort of Renny type
shop in a Curry House you know like a
liqueur but like they say you know you
could order it secretly under the box
I'm sure I did my intestines damage but
there is there is something like a
boisterous about about a curry that
obviously appeals so it's another one of
those surface things where you go it's
really easy to sell what blokes or
Basics they like Curry but why why do
they like Curry and because yeah you can
sort of prove your metal this is an
element of risk involved yeah well Jeff
it's uh it's great to have you on to
talk about this stuff and um uh I hope
everybody reads the book The British
bloke decoder but uh let's take a few
minutes before we we move on to locals
to talk about politics because it's
obviously you as a comedian you you
comment on stuff and make jokes about it
we've had a bunch of lefties on the show
in recent weeks and months as we build
up to what will be uh almost certainly a
labor government at this point coming
yeah what do you think about that well
it'll be the biggest party I would have
thought yeah I don't think I don't know
what could happen I mean like
governments generally get voted out when
the economy is is bad and they will
continually continue to be bad I mean
all the pointers are 13 years you know
there have been scandals which you know
some have been overblown some some have
been valid but I think the main thing is
that people feel skin and historically
people tend to get fired out and also
labor of sort it's just weird things
happen in British politics whereby all
the all the grown-ups are in the room
right which obviously is a really tragic
way to refer to yourself with the
grown-ups in the makes you think of Will
from the in-betweeners that's sort of
like the kind of thing that he would say
but they talk about the last you know
the brexit type here of politics is the
least edifying in British political
history and there's some truth in that
Johnson Hiding in the fridge Corbin and
you know his issues I do think there's
also something unedefined about a prime
minister who's currently just looking
for a grift you know literally Rishi is
going down the list of diminishing
returns to motorists I'll be the
motorist guy yeah I'll be the guy with
cars and so he's been these the boats
I'll be about the boats you know because
there's so little left after 13 years in
power for him to attach himself to but
equally on the other side you've got the
leader of the opposition who's just
gleefully auctioned enough every last
principle and policy he's ever had and
yet you get people like you know
Alistair Campbell and Rory Stewart so
well thank God the grown-ups who are
back in the room because this is it's
just a better quality period of politics
you go well the Optics might be better
I'd agree with that but the underlying
principles of what's Happening as we
come up on the next election or arguably
not maybe not just as bad but they're
not great are they and and and there is
something I mean I wasn't going to talk
about politics as much on the next tour
uh basic bloke you know some British
bloke decoded basically I'm trying to
start a Marvel cinematics of the Blokus
sphere and but I do think politics has
become funny again I think it's a lot
funnier than it was under Corbin and
Johnson because you got this star who's
this just he obviously he's got the
voice which is a bit ridiculous but also
him and him and sunak they just look
like they they just soon that just looks
like he just won Junior Apprentice yeah
you know just sitting there grinning
just as he seemed I don't think it
should be problem to be small and be
prime minister yeah all to be young but
I think being young and small you know
yeah it does look like a child and he's
and he's got anyways ankle swingers as
well he wears ankle swingers he can't
take a man seriously with Uncle and he's
so Keen you know it's a bit the keenness
is a bit much and then starmer who just
looks like a sort of life insurance
salesman that decided he wanted to be
king and and this this you know two it
just feels like two bald men fighting
over an ideology
there's so little between them now the
truth of the matter is is that they they
both represent politics I don't know I'm
center right so in terms of what they
actually broadly will represent it's not
a million miles away from me but in
terms of politics to get excited about
politics to motivate politics to have a
discussion about it's it's absolutely
it's absolutely bereft I mean the idea
that you know the way that the same
group of people who are saying that you
should never lie to win elections you
know and that now seem to have forgotten
that principle and they're just every
time some stalma junks and other ideas
oh well it's just what you've got to say
to an election yeah all right because
before you were saying that that was
basically fascism but it
the thing are fun really into thing
about Labor is that you ask me a single
labor policy and I'm someone who
followed politics and it's a politics
nerd I don't think I'd be able to tell
you one all that labor have really done
is just stood back and let the
conservatives make an ass of it that's
really all they've done yeah and I think
that you could understand that
strategically up to a point it's almost
been like labor because if you
people forget that Tories was still
ahead going into October 2021 and then
your imperson thing happened then party
get happened each thing dropped to an
English trust happened so what labor
have in terms of a poll lead is
effectively like a surprise inheritance
from a mad Uncle their life was just
going along it wasn't really that good
and then there was suddenly a letter
from a lawyer arrived you've won a 15
point lead in the polls through nothing
you've done and that that worries me
actually because to get a poll lead it
means that then they've got this issue
which is we best just not [__] it up
let's not do anything and let's not say
anything and that was fair for a time I
do think a year out with the poses they
are it's not unreasonable to ask to say
to labor
um what would you do and the answer
increasingly seems to be roughly the
same but with less scandals yeah and
also as well there's that mental side of
the yeah on our voted labor there's that
mental side of the left and Stormer has
done a pretty good job actually of kind
of marginalizing them but they're always
there ready to come roaring back with
their demented ideas and policies which
when you see things you know like like
the Tavistock etc etc it really worries
me well that's the question I suppose is
like labor have got these big
institutions and you go to what he's
thinking one person at the center who
doesn't yet have a mandate uh isn't that
popular really doesn't Infuse or Inspire
anybody to what extent can he be bigger
than the the NEC you know or the unions
or the labor parliamentary party all of
those three things are still world to
the maybe not economically left to the
country these days but maybe country to
the left so that is I guess if they're
wanting to vote of somebody like me you
think could you lend labor your vote
um you go who wouldn't be in power once
I could absolutely see the situation
where labor win a landslide and then
junk starmer after 18 months because
they would think right it's enough time
to get a new person in enact Napoli's
policies that we really want to do and
then when next election based on well
they wouldn't but that's what they think
would happen you know they I don't think
that the weirdly the the sort of main
pledges of the Corby Manifesto are still
a big guide in force for a lot of the
left and I think the British public
probably probably agree with a lot of
them but not all at the same time the
problem with the people on the hard lift
is like let's [__] do it all and you
go all right maybe nationalize the
trains maybe no profit on water Let's do
let's do those now and see how it goes
then let's [__] do all of them yeah
let's take it all back in the state
control and I think that you know storm
is shrewd enough to see that the public
weren't ready for that they still aren't
ready for that but that's my Wonder is
that you know obviously if you want a
big election there will be a mandate
just forever being voted in I could just
I could if I was if there's a way of
putting a bet on that the labor would
win an election and then and then junk
stalma I'd put that bet on that's
interesting and one of the things as
well as I remember the first time we had
you on we talked about a working class
Tory voter and you and I was sort of
saying it's a bit unheard of and you're
all I actually know you know Monday or
man and yeah whatever and I think one of
the things that has often uh attracted
people from that background to what to
voting for a thatcher let's say it's the
idea of aspiration this idea that we're
going to build an economy which if you
you if you put your shoulder to the
wheel you're gonna you're gonna do well
right
do you see that from either party on the
table at the moment well if you look at
what the toys have done right going
right back to 2010 you could make a sort
of a conservative
um party promo or an election sort of
leaflet based on a very left-wing agenda
right they could say that they've
reduced the amount dramatically that you
can get in terms of dividends you know
they've they actually the first time I
really heard about uh tax avoidance was
in the early years of the Coalition in
2010 remember the boycott Starbucks
though a lot of that came from Cameron
Ann Osborne's rhetoric you know they
weren't saying boycott but um but it
came from stuff that they were saying if
you look at the way that they've changed
the rules around the expenses that you
can claim as second landlords they've
put they've literally given people money
through covid you know they've put up
taxes you could you could honestly make
like this really great banging left-wing
poster for the conservative party but
they're slightly embarrassed about that
you know in the same way that labor
would be slightly uneasy so with some of
the more right with right-wing things
they've done so it's really interesting
thing where people talk about how
right-wing you know it's always the
worst right-wing government in history
and you know culturally I guess you know
with some of the stances on immigration
but the thing is stances but they're not
actually not doing it some of the
rhetoric You could argue well they've
actually achieved on immigration not
really
um but yeah but if you talk about actual
economics nothing could be further from
from right and it just seems to me like
we're in this place where is that
whatever the problem is there's only one
answer which is more government
interference in everything do you know
what I mean and I know you you you're
someone who sort of talks about the
nanny State and I don't even mean like
the government's deciding how much tax
to put in your Weetabix or whatever I
mean you know when covert comes along
let's do it when gas prices go up the
government can it's it's sort of like
every big problem you never ever no one
is ever responsible for their own lives
really because when you fall the
government's always there to like pick
you up you're like a little child you
know I've definitely noticed since kovid
like the the is always more government
spending you know the idea that even
with pay rise settlements really you go
and sometimes we just we get a bit
poorer because of what's happening right
you know that you know sometimes we
might get richer because of how the
economy is right has been performing but
the problem with covert is it drew this
sort of like year zero if anything bad
happens the government need to sort it
out and and you know we the effects of
Doubt are obvious with inflation
everything that I mean it's just so
everything that people said would cause
inflation has caused inflation right and
then people say well let's have more of
those things it's insane and it has made
me lose quite a lot of respect for the
conservative party that I feel like
there were certain key principles during
covid that they had a real gut instinct
on one of which was not shot in the
schools right I really think that they
knew that was [__] terrible for the
academic development of those children
God knows how many families got divorced
and they were told at the time they were
told and then we find out laterally
through some of these WhatsApp so part
of it was because they wanted to avoid a
fight with Nicholas sturgeon so you know
I don't know I don't think I'm in a
place to vote labor it's very hard for
me to consider that but when you talk
about voting conservatives your party
gate is one thing cake you know
hypocrisy that policy alone and the
amount of people they had an impact on I
find it very hard to get past that with
the conservatives they knew what the
right thing to do was but they shut the
school they're all right they shut the
schools the first time extraordinary
circumstances but when it happened a
second time yeah I was genuinely stunned
and let down yeah yeah and look also as
well and I can't believe I'm going to
say these words but I'm going to say
them as a remainder I don't think I can
forgive forgive labor for brexit for
just the way that they ignored their
Heartland their Community the people
that they purported to represent and
then you've got someone like Mick Lynch
come along and they all you know they
all start worshiping Mick Lynch and go
isn't he brilliant hang on mate he said
died in the world Gammon brexit here so
at what point did he stop being a racist
and he'd become the face for the left
that you will love well yeah I mean we
yeah I uh is he is he what is Gammon is
well why working class you know and a
bit older yeah
you know pinkish skin yeah I'm Paul
Gammon yeah you've got hair mate yeah a
dinosaur is is one thing that I'm
increasingly called but I mean going
back to your point I get yeah those were
a bunch of criticisms that were
laterally applied to some people I think
the thing with with Mick Lynch it was it
was interesting for me because I like
the way the guy communicating very
effective Union Union management Union
man reminded me of guys that are new
growing up but it was suddenly funny
like oh guys like Mick Lynch are back in
fashion but if you think this and then
it's like but what about what make
things Mick thinks about brexit they're
like you know we all have our blind
spots yeah but they didn't they didn't
want to talk about that but like a lot
of what he said about brexit was you
know incredibly valid I think when it
comes to labor stance on brexit they've
lately realized
you you know they they I mean stalma was
the architect of it that's the irony and
a lot of people on the hard left notice
right I'm not telling anything they
don't know he he come up with these
these sort of semantic straight jacket
which was right we got the six tests of
brexit but if it delivers all this then
we'll support him one of them was like
the reintroductions of unicorns into the
world there's a whole bunch of things
that weren't like sort of possible so
it's hard to take with starving you go
you've literally just done like a
complete flip and it's strange because I
now have a bit of empathy for the
corbinister supports because it's just
so it's so rich coming from him who who
literally led the party towards a
position of a second referendum where
remain was an option which was
effectively you know to to so but you
could absolutely argue that brexit was
the wrong thing but I just think that
that weird period where people thought
that the people could vote for a thing
and the thing might not might not happen
without even being tried that seems like
a strange time now but starma starma was
a part of that but the other side of it
is that the Tories ever since you know
brexit just seems to become more
European that that's the you know in
terms of Regulation and stuff it was
they were sort of sold Singapore on sea
and it's now what Brussels on the Thames
is what you know so yeah I mean I think
politically if you come to the next door
it's very much a plague on both their
houses yeah yeah well that that was very
apt for the moment that we're in Japan
and the final thing before we ask you uh
our last question and move on to locals
where we're continuing the conversation
um
what do you want to happen in the next
election because some people would say
well look the conservative party is not
doing what it's supposed to be doing
they need a kicking so that they
actually go away and rethink things yeah
possibly I mean I think the five years
of Labor if it's the kind of Labor that
Stormer is suggesting it might not be
too bad if it kind of flips early in the
the life of the government there's a lot
of damage that could be done in in a
short space of time
um I think that it's hard you know I I
am sort of I'm not tribally conservative
but I have voted conservative since 2010
but like a lot of people I've drifted uh
away from that you know the honest
answer and this is not you know if
somebody's invested in politics is that
I honestly don't care that much who gets
in because I don't think it'll be you
know that that different and I do Wonder
as well if actually just from a social
media point of view it'd be good to have
five years of Labor so just for those
people that have operated with complete
hypothetical moral certainty for the
last 13 years that everything they vote
for if that had happened everything
would have been fine they get to sort of
experience the the sort of uh the burden
of success which is that you get held
accountable for what you voted for
because it's really interesting at the
moment where you know it's particularly
at the time where the center is sort of
back in charge is that and there's a
sort of veneration of the John major
types and the new labor years people
sort of forget the stuff that happened
under new labor very early into the life
of the government uh there was
interviews about cash for questions you
know people quitting there was mandelson
there was Iraq you know there was all
this stuff that's all way [__] bigger
in some respects and anything that's
happened in the last few years so I
think that labor will find it hard once
they get in because you've never had
more time of politicians in front more
news outlets more people every time you
put a minister in front of a camera
that's a [__] up waiting to happen right
so when we were kids it was the news at
10 and news at six now it's all day long
you've always got people out there just
ready with that big size night to put
your foot into it in terms of leagues
now you've got more cameras you've got
more WhatsApp groups more leagues so I
think the idea is that labor well
they'll just do it roughly the same but
their conduct will be better I think
they might run a tight ship initially
but it's very hard to run stable
government you know in this kind of
media age so I would think that do you
know sort of like mischievously there's
a part of me that one wants to see that
happen to remind people that that con
bad conduct in government it can be
non-binary and also just on a basic
level I'd love to see you know all these
accounts that all they do all day is go
the Tories oh the Tories I hate this
[__] government what are you going to
Tweet about now
because I'm sure that they would say
oh we will hold Labor's feet to the
Flames I reckon they'll do that for
about a month and then it'll be back to
photos of their lunch yeah I'm sure and
uh lovely to hear you talk about your
colleagues in the comedy industry
I was I was thinking of those
celebrities that have suddenly yeah
no one's listening to me anymore oh you
know it's [__] yeah the Tories good luck
family yeah
it's great to have you back on the show
we're going to continue the conversation
on locals where uh our audience have
already submitted a bunch of questions
for you but we always under the same
last question which is what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should be
um I suppose
all right
right we always talk about how bad
social media is and how what a polluting
effect that it's had on our discourse I
think that in years to come we'll
reflect on how rolling news was actually
a bigger thing because at that point
there was a time when the news was a
thing that happened maybe three times a
day once in the morning once at
lunchtime early evening late at night
the the field that there always has to
be a story yeah is really pollutant and
actually the the news discussion on
social media is just an extension of
that principle there's always a story
there's always a trend you know you
never get like nothing's trending today
nothing's big and and so I think that
role in news has ceded that idea and may
you know so then you have to almost drag
things into the slipstream of big news
that wouldn't have otherwise been worthy
I mean the stuff that gets called
breaking news now
this you go when I was a kid it was like
literally there to be a coup you know
what I mean they had to be a coup and
even if it was a bloodless coup they go
well maybe not today you know so I think
depending on the geography mate like
south of Sudan no one yeah yeah I mean
there's obviously a proximity yeah and
in some reason America but like but yeah
I think that you know in the history
books when they look forward they'll
probably think that
um the role in news was really a bigger
deal in some respects and also just
finding more of a frivolous note is the
true crime genre
I think the amount of money has been
made about murders actually I mean birds
love all that birds love that oh they
[__] do they uh I just find it
genuinely weird the amount of money
that's made out of murder of all the
crimes right is the worst if you ask me
would I rather be sexually assaulted or
killed I'd probably take my chances with
the sexual assault and yeah murder on
the Orient Express A Time to Kill man
look at all the titles if you just
Google film with the word murder or
killing
she's got a channel called unfathomable
crimes she just bangs on about unsolved
murders and women love it they
absolutely love a psychopath okay so
maybe that's my next book
women absolutely love a psychopath they
do they do they do they genuinely do I
think it's a thing of like women want to
find a bloke who is a psychopath but not
with them yeah I can change him yeah
yeah Ted Bundy If he if he'd been with
me exactly all right they love it they
love it
if there's any women who want to watch
it it's a great a great podcast idea I
could change him or you take the worst
serial killers in history and three
women put forward views of how they
could have made him a different person I
could have tamed Fred West I could have
tamed Fred West that wasn't that Rose
West's biography yeah and a dark um
anyway perfect well come over onto
locals uh but before you do make sure
you buy the book uh the British bloke
decoded and of course basic block is the
tour uh Jeff will be in Edinburgh uh
during the month of August and not going
on tour around the rest of the country
from September onwards make sure you do
that follow us over to locals where we
continue the conversation
what's the biggest animal you think you
can kill with your bare hands if you had
to
[Music]